all right mark Marcus use me all right
buddy
how do we do teams how does Stevens even
work in this so only one of us has to
win for us both to win we work together
one of us empty our hands okay we can
see each other's cards oh I can see your
cards
yeah how am I supposed to be able to pay
attention to that by looking at them
don't forget zeros the sevens are on so
those change our hands okay all right
here we go all right okay wait that
doesn't help me okay what should I
should i do wait it's up to you man my
hands not really helpful you in place
haven't see what Jack's gonna do that
give me that
I feel so helped aha your turn I got
this one on luck ha ha ha ha my turn ha
ha ha
for [ __ ] shitsnacks
that's crazy [ __ ] you're playing right
yeah I know man I live on the edge I did
not see that coming you know yeah ok no
mama
yeah oh god why last night
oh yeah I'll turn around like this thank
you color I appreciate that
immensely actually actually and but like
and actually don't don't do it don't
don't no I have a strategy I have a
strategy wait why did I get two cards
because you didn't play in time okay
okay that's cool all right yeah what
about it say a little no Perino on that
one yeah that didn't work very well
today
yeah neither did buddy team here working
together I'm just gonna keep getting two
cards wait don't do it wait don't thank
you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well [ __ ] it's okay bark I got a plan I
don't have any cards execute it all
right fine oh yeah well I got a plan I
got a plan you take now Jack's probably
got a plan
Wow ring-around-the-rosy suede well [ __ ]
yeah play somethin play somethin there
you go wait wait wait oh god why okay I
will eat your ate with my eight okay how
about we do this yes yes yes I'm sorry
mark but Jack has a lot of cards to
damage you with yeah I know it's okay I
want I want Jack's hand back so he can't
use it on you
oh thank you I think yeah okay I guess
that makes sense
fair plays fair play I suppose I guess
Bobby you know what to do how about a
little bit of this action oh did you
want the other one
oh god all right so I I don't want a
dirty house
oh god I'm sorry yes oh yes he's gotta
Fred yo this is not gonna help them good
come on Zach
you can don't really have a lot to do to
help me no he's got his okay it's not
the color
he's it's all right all right okay here
we go what'd you do not agree on funny
stuff all right okay I'm just gonna
comedy make it I know I know I got you
Oh
[Music]
sorry way Oh God
stretchy just went downhill fast
Oh ha ha that did not help you at all
I could have made that so much better
for you
I didn't I apologize I apologize I could
have done that good wait I could have
done that good for you yeah you know
we're and you know you're not
Thanks yeah I didn't sorry I wasn't
thinking
I wasn't thinking like a team player
didn't think it might you know just
crashed Marc so good luck with the AR
[Music]
Wade Luna Lou no thank you
interesting play I can't believe that
one just happened look at this one ah
thank God just to make sure it's okay
because I've got this up my sleeve [ __ ]
you got extra cards up your sleeve off
years old
no how many great cards I have now
computer robot it seems to be
malfunctioning internal processor is
building with you don't know that
because I got this presser oh you think
you guys all right cuz take this
this yeah you even see anything are you
just [ __ ] around that again okay yeah
we know we know what's going on over
there you know no but check out this
that's all right I've got some good ones
here there's a couple plus fours
well [ __ ] yeah wait wait you don't have
any plus force all right Plus chase I
have an idea
Oh how about I play a skip ha ha
joke's on you Bob geez I can't remember
what you owe
how about already it made me draw cards
after you win
[Laughter]
cards lose their weight we lost yeah you
have this eight you lose oh it still
happened we haven't lost yet no we lost
all right wait set us up again everybody
all right here have a zero I'm flipping
it around totally gonna be quieter okay
then you should be able to send in vote
okay Hobby Lobby please don't do that
[Laughter]
you're just like oh [ __ ] don't talk
we're gonna kick their asses Timur sobs
Wow
oh yeah just well you get this oh [ __ ]
man yeah I didn't know you had one Bob
and and then we're gonna go like this
[Laughter]
[Music]
doesn't matter now does it
yeah because it wasn't us it wasn't a
selfish manner Oh is a self-sacrificing
maneuver what I guess I don't know it's
a bad idea but I'll do it yeah I'm good
I'm playing support defense just love on
[Music]
wait
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what you're saying is yeah couldn't
agree more
nice you can't do that
[Laughter]
you know I've got some things to say to
you about that [ __ ] [ __ ] you only
postpone the inevitable oh yeah stop
telling my car big fat all right you
ready take some that thank you
Jack sorry I didn't help you at all
[Laughter]
that I know that you know God why okay
this works this work this works this
works this way like you don't want to
make it one of the ones you have
probably not one of the ones how's it
feel to be skipped to be skipped
oh I set you up for marks hand is
basically a Cara fire oh that's good one
oh I want to see more I wanna see more
[Laughter]
Wade you know no waiting oh wait
actually yes so funny you're looking for
you left it blue Wade oh why you do this
[ __ ] it's okay Bob I got a [ __ ] huh I
got this actually do it Jack do it jack
do it to it actually oh do anyway Jack
it's skipping between you guys thanks
Bob it's fine just leave it it's fine I
guess I could do about it
do I Bob we're doing oh I think you do I
think you do I really think you do but
this is okay telepathy unfair I mean I
just gave him an equally good hand got a
red oh there we go I don't know Holly oh
I did click it though [ __ ] [ __ ] you oh
really yeah it's a red don't change it
to red no one [ __ ] ass red just calm
down
[Laughter]
Oh
oh yes so and other what I'm doing Oh
[Laughter]
cows rain your [ __ ] you oh yeah check
you to do nope I'll just like a giant I
took it yeah thanks yeah get him again
mark oh you know I will
cuz I'm gonna do that one okay yeah yeah
man because of strats and reasons mm-hmm
that's some tasty strats i see over
there okay I'll just send that along oh
yeah yeah sure dude don't I know about
it
Oh for god sakes
oh [ __ ] this is K that works
[Laughter]
Bobby no I can't do anything
Wade you know what to do yeah I know
what to do okay okay no no don't worry
about don't worry about don't worry
about it don't worry about it don't
worry about it
Bob don't worry about worrying about
don't worry about it
as you should try I don't think there's
anything we could have done Oh No what
color are they yeah I don't know what
everyone has in their hand white okay
Jack Jack you know what to do check you
know what wasn't it no that wasn't it no
that was not the thing to do dear me Oh
Oh my loins are so tender for the fear
what yeah I'm gonna do it oh thanks
buddy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
all right well haha now I remember what
we had yeah this could work out all yes
they don't have one of those you don't
know that I forget what they have don't
make it yellow don't make it yellow got
it there there we go what good I think
you're stupid ggwp you're still good
Jackie don't do ya buddy
Oh Jackie yeah how do you like those
lemons I'm gonna get rid of cards more
than anything else I kind of have my
dick in ass okay I solved it yay Jack
Jack Jack played you I did that right no
no your self again I thought Gigi
[Music]